in five four three two welcome everybody
to the h3 podcast experience and since
its ends we are joan oil first of all
before I forget we are sponsored today
by policy genius quip honey and stitch
fix and today we are joined by the
Renaissance man prolific individual
Bobby Hall aka logic
what's goodie who is a one of our most
requested guests of all time we didn't
say really oh people are pretty fired up
at electric about this episode so I
thank you so much for coming and joining
us today it's a treasure to have you
I appreciate it I'm happy to be here I
was telling my buddies in the car that
I'm like nervous I'm never nervous for
interviews because I'm always like
alright whatever
but there's a there's a few interviews
that I love doing I'm not gonna like
promote a bunch of other people but like
Naru are you know nargile of nard wah
buddy of mine Nick like there's these
different just sources that I go to that
are super cool and fun and then I look
forward to but this is like an
experience right I am yeah thank you
yeah yeah very sweet of you to say I'm
nervous I get nervous every episode I
was just saying yeah I have anxiety
problems I get nervous every episode I
wish you know I always talked to comics
and performers and they're like I was
like to get nervous like I was talking
to Bill burr and he did a show us in was
it in New York
the gardens or whatever there's like fit
33 both yeah house like do what Madison
Square Gardens
yeah the gardens but I was like do you
get nervous cuz that's like a big show
and he's like now I you know I used to
get nervous I don't get nervous anymore
I get nervous every time and I'm just
seeing in a room it's just three of us
no I mean everybody does it different
when I played the gardens yeah oh you
played the guard I did gradual I thank
you very much excellent that was fun I
wasn't really that nervous I was more so
excited but that's the thing it's like
when you do something a thousand times
in a row yeah it's yeah it's kind of
like I don't know how to explain it it's
just you get used to it but it's not
that you get something you know you
don't care you're not excited it's just
you're like it's kind of
a job but when you do stuff like this
because I'm like such a fan of you guys
and I've been watching your videos for
everyone do since we first met you owe
me you remember when we met right yeah
at Justin roiland town and you guys were
super cool and chill and I was we were
like whole area with the [ __ ] wait can I
guess yeah you can and if you want ya
[ __ ] juice anything but ya know I met
you guys there and you were super cool
I'll check these two out and I've been
like standing that's super sweet well
finally the first time the first time I
ran a new found out about you we went
and saw you with Mac DeMarco he was like
hey do you want to go see this I wanna
go see logic with us yeah and I was like
yeah that sounds fun I didn't know who
you were but the show was it was at the
Greek yeah
the show was let the audience was just
they're so electric bro your fans are
Saints so passionate yeah that's one
thing that Irish show was amazing
tonight
any played Mario Cart on stage yeah and
then what did I play after that I played
something else
Street Fighter on the next tour did
Street Fighter no I really pride myself
in my fans because I feel I don't know
their I just don't necessarily know like
I feel like maybe they feel about me
kind of how I felt about Kid Cudi like
here was this guy coming in like talking
about his feelings and emotions and all
the [ __ ] and it said that was like them
a time that was kind of like weird to do
that and he just was himself so I don't
know um you know I've always been like
nerdy and I love sci-fi and books and
movies and this and I just integrate all
that into the music but the biggest
thing above all was just always the you
know peace love and positivity and doing
what you love and for a long time in
hip-hop when I was doing my thing I was
definitely scrutinized because of it you
know it was like people would call me
too nice or this has got to be fake or
it's not real and then obviously you
know just time time tells the story and
it's just honest so being able to have
thousands of people who are like-minded
who enjoy a guy who can you know have
fun rapping but talk about a positive
message and just be himself is really
cool but it is hard to be yourself I'll
tell you that it's hard yeah it's not
ironic that just being yourself is so
difficult
yeah it should be the most natural thing
in the world right hey I'm just being
myself yeah it seems like a tough crowd
especially like being
hey pop yeah definitely it's it's wild
hip-hop is to me it's just like the
epitome of pop culture now it's like
just it's the most I don't know like
loved and it's quick it's crazy that I
can like hear a country song and it's
like driving down the street and my Ford
truck and then you hear like these like
808s and like and I'm like holy [ __ ]
everywhere yeah it's really wild yeah
but honestly like true hip-hop like true
lovers of hip-hop and true journalists
and true like I've always received love
from that I mean [ __ ] wu-tang clan
was all my you know so I've always
gotten the love and respect from like
what hip-hop really is and hip-hop is
beautiful and it's you know it's
definitely burst by you know incredible
black people but it's something that has
been shared and has allowed many doors
to open for all cultures and races to
come together so to me like real hip-hop
is built on love and and diversity and
differences and accepting others and
regardless if you agree or not but to be
able to peacefully just speak your mind
mm-hmm yeah what do you think about like
terms like just because you bring up the
idea that black people mm-hmm brought
about hip hop and a lot of the musical
movements on yeah jazz rock and roll
right yeah I mean really All American
music is kind of has origins in yeah in
black culture definitely what do you
think about the terms of that I hear a
lot being thrown out like cultural
vulture and stuff like that I think it's
a real thing yeah but but it depends you
know I mean like people have said that
about me you like just like on comments
it's why I don't really don't know how
you could say that about you I don't
understand that either but it's it's
almost like what I've learned is is I
don't understand hate because I'm not
hater I'm a lover it's that simple so
it's like me just telling it like it is
is you know I came from nothing
the fans out there will know I came from
section 8 household welfare food stamps
you know cocaine being cooked on the
stove drug dealers murderers in and out
of my house and coming out of that and
rising above it and actually talking
about it and making it out and having
some fun and you know making some
kickass raps while doing it you think
people would just be like
damn this is dope but perception is a
big thing how I look my race my swerve
my skin color all this other stuff
people do it's just a big I mean Drake
said it best at the Grammys you know
there's a lot of people in positions of
power who for them it's more so kind of
like a it's like a political game you
know if you look the part and you kind
of act apart then you can be more
accepted as if you don't like I don't
know it's weird but that's the one thing
that is odd is I've always been myself
and then people are like oh like they
could say you know I'm corny because I
like sci-fi or I rap about it or this or
that or bubblebobbler so you could call
me what you want but at least I'm myself
and I've said this since the beginning
of my career rather be hated for who I
am than love for who I'm not yeah what
do you you said you find it hard to be
yourself do you find these external
forces of everyone having expectations
and judging you and kind of not allowing
a lot of people not allowing you to be a
part of whatever culture they belong to
do you find that they're these external
forces are sometimes making it difficult
to be yourself do you ever find yourself
being swayed by their their opinions and
their perceptions and you know what I'm
saying you know no I can directly get
yourself
yeah see I've always felt accepted by
hip-hop as I said you know like true oh
geez that built our culture love me and
I love them and like I didn't have a dad
growing up and so I listened to NAS and
Tribe Called Quest and Big L and you
know all these amazing emcees and like
learned a lot from them you know so I've
always felt accepted by the culture that
is a loving hip-hop mm-hmm
but it's more so like blogs and back in
the day of blogs and [ __ ] excuse me and
just kind of like the tastemakers or
this or that and I just felt like I had
to push my way through to try I don't
all I know is I stopped giving a [ __ ]
after like my first album yeah cuz I
really wanted to be loved and accepted
so bad and I still do you want to be
accepted but you're not totally you know
what I've realized is you have to truly
first and foremost love and accept
yourself all right it's the same reason
I'm not on Instagram all the time in
social media anymore and it really hurts
me to say that because every day all the
time since 2000
ten nine or ten whenever I created my
account I was on it all the time every
day like my for one of my first fans
ever her name is Larissa Larissa
she's Native American we call her an
initial her name and like that's still
my homie like I see her on every tour I
go on like and and these were people
that I've connected with I can't tell
you how many times I go to concerts and
I see somebody in the front row or five
people in the front row that have been
to ten shows already on that tour or a
tour from before there's this girl I
forgot I don't even know her name
I always forget her name but I remember
her cuz she's blue coat girl and she'll
always bring a sign that says blue coat
girl and the first time I did the
shelter in or no I wasn't the shelter
but anyway in Detroit and it was
freezing outside and she wore this blue
coat and then I saw her again in Florida
and she was like remember me blue coat
and it's just like I know that I'm loved
and accepted by the people that matter
most and then and that's that's it
because the thing is as artists and as
creatives you know just like yourselves
you create the content for people who
enjoy it not to people who don't I know
so you so hard you know I agree I I have
the same the same issue or hold on dance
giving me not was this ten Oh
Adam your manager says is her name
apparently that's what Dan says shout
out autumn yeah blue cool girls more of
a title of honor though it to be yes no
it can't totally I have the same I've
been going through some similar issues
works like the people that don't even
wish you well the people that don't even
care about like your work or your
well-being or anything are the ones that
can be so overbearing li- yeah and most
the you know most of the people that
enjoy just consume it and move on
yeah they don't usually bother to share
their thoughts anywhere and so it's so
there's there's almost like a
confirmation bias like what the feedback
you received because like on a YouTube
video you'll read the comments
and a lot of times the negative one will
flow to the top because a lot of people
who have that similar negativity are
looking for that comment yeah and
they're there there's maybe there
there's so much less of them but they're
all looking for that one negative
comment to be like yeah but the message
is we also look for the negative I know
as you see a million positive comments
like think about it I actually I'm
working on an album right now I'm not
gonna say what it everything about it
but I do talk about social media and
effects the effects of it not only on me
as a young man but you know your average
social media user and as well as other
artists alike it's crazy to me for
example rest in peace like you know Mac
Miller could pass away from you know
drug use but it's deeper than just the
drug use we have to understand that it's
it's it's coping you know what I mean
with the things that we're dealing with
and it's kind of messed up to say this
as like you know you see it as like a 1%
it's like oh people don't know what it's
like for me and you know and then you
have somebody's like oh we got millions
of dollars and you're rich and you're
loved and you're this and you're that
and it's like yeah sure but just imagine
knowing that right now millions of
people are [ __ ] on me right now yeah
like there's just somebody out there
just cheating on me
and you have to like cope and understand
that and that's why it is so sad because
you know a lot of artists human beings
people in general will turn to substance
or this or this and it isn't just drugs
it's alcoholism or it's even the drug
that is social media instructed behavior
yes social media because it's a again
and part like when you're depressed and
you have everything in the world you
know that that people associate with
like success and Happiness when you have
all those things and you still feel bad
it makes it even worse yeah right
because people don't care as much they
don't want to listen and you feel like
what is wrong with me
even more but if they're but there's
nothing wrong with you because happiness
is internal and it's a personal journey
so it's like you could have all the
money in the world and money can 100%
buy you comfort it's like oh yeah I can
go on this vacation but if you're like
depressed in the Sun then what the [ __ ]
is it doesn't really matter again who
described it like this but when you have
money and comfort and everything in life
that that you need all that's left is
the mental aspect yeah
because you if you have problems in your
life you can go grind a 9 to 5 and you
have bowls like I just want to save
enough for this new car for this new
apartment or whatever but when all those
goals and all those motivating forces
that kind of distract you or give you
purpose are gone then really all that
you're left with is the mental yeah but
it's like it's then what and that's
something that I had to look into like
with myself like I was I was like really
working myself to death you know it's
why I'm happy that I look healthy I feel
healthy I'm eating right I'm working out
and I wasn't doing that before and and
it's I had to ask myself ok what's the
end right when I first started it was oh
man if I if people could just listen to
my music then they'd listen to the music
oh man if I could just have followers
and then you get flowers oh my god I got
fans well if I could just release a
project then you release the project oh
man if I could get a record deal then
you get record deal like the biggest
thing in the world for me was the you
know the double XL freshmen covers do
you guys know about this no it's like
the it is the epitome of you've you've
made it except you haven't made it yet
by putting you on double XLS freshmen
cover and so I was on there with Travis
Scott in Action Bronson all these
incredible artists and I did that I'm
like oh my god then it's like ok get
your record deal I got your record deal
then it's ok put out an album and then
you think and then you put out an album
and you're like wait there's so much
more still to be done then you put out a
second um then it's okay alright I'm
touring at like 200 cap you know two
hundred people are coming to see me but
then it's five hundred then it's two
thousand and it's five thousand then you
do the garden so then you're sitting
there I'm sitting at the Grammys you
know nominated for song and song of the
year which I didn't take home but it
doesn't matter I was like oh my god I'm
here Grammys so it's like you're at the
Grammys you've been recognized you're
selling out arenas
well now what mm-hmm and I was like
pretty [ __ ] up for a while but it
seemed the depression that I went
through I didn't know I didn't realize I
was depressed which is a weird thing
because I was I was counting all my
blessings I'm like I'm surrounded by
incredible people that are my family my
best friends I have fans all over the
world but then you look back in
retrospect and it was like yeah but I
felt so empty why how did I feel so
empty because I wasn't truly fulfilling
myself I was just making hip hop album
after hip hop out mind you
putting my heart and soul into every
song for sure without a court without
question but it was still like
repetition it was still the same thing
and that's why I've been you know
playing the piano and you know singing
over guitar and having fun and branching
out doing film as well which is very
important because I need other outlets
that are that's not just music however
I'm not gonna like turn my back on music
music is not only my my bread and butter
but it's my my main source of true
creative form of expression and therapy
but I've just realized for me personally
you got to do other [ __ ] but the biggest
thing I had to do was live my life right
yeah enjoy I think also you just have to
learn to not be so focused on the goal
and like suffer all the way through so
and understand that you gotta enjoy your
everyday too while you're working
towards our goal that was the biggest
thing I had to learn cuz the before
you're like I'm just focused on these
goals like I got to put out an album
yeah and once I get dialed on everything
will be amazing yeah but when you get mm
it's like you don't even think about
you're just like this is it it's so
distracting and it's so motivating and
you just work every day it's what
motivates you and you never stop and
think about like what anything that's
wrong in your personal life right or
your mental life and and once that goal
is achieved then you no longer have that
purpose and yes [ __ ] no it's insane I
completely agree I think that's like the
biggest thing that I learned with and I
still learned like you know I have a
tattoo here that says look around and
another one that says balance yourself
and that is a huge deal is actually
enjoying the journey it's funny I was
telling my friends this that back in the
basement in Lenny's basement when I had
no job no money no anything you know he
let me live with him for a year big
limbo and when that year was up I signed
my deal to Def Jam told him to quit his
job at 12 years and we moved to LA and
we've been going ever since but I would
always in the moment be like damn like I
don't wanna be in this basement
I don't wanna be broke I don't wanna be
this and I was constantly looking
forward to this other thing that's why
now in film I'm loving every moment of
it like there's so much [ __ ] like I'm
working I'm doing a movie right now that
I won't get too much into it's it's
another film about stand-up comedy which
I'm really
I did too I've already written it it's
really exciting and I'm funding it
myself for a nice amount of money and
but it's because I believe in it so much
and there's days when I wake up and I'm
like [ __ ] I wish I was on set already or
damn I wish I was at the movie theater
watching this with the world or at the
premiere but then I remember dude like
you had those memories in the basement
we're like the best memories of your
life hmm
so stop focusing on the goal and you
know enjoy the million producer meetings
you have to meet with and directors and
actors like soak it all up yeah yeah
it's tough it's so hard to keep things
in context but it's so important
otherwise you just lose yourself mm-hmm
I mean I had like a mental breakdowns
kind of recently I'm better now a little
better but that's normal bro it's normal
but do you know how hard it is to do
that [ __ ] in front of the whole world
yeah no it was it was it was a very
personal experience though but it's nice
to be able to share it with people and
for them to to listen yes I started
taking antidepressants and I started
going to therapy for the first time I go
to therapy it's great yeah it is it's so
important to it like it gives new
context to everything in my life
yeah and makes you dig down god I
realize how awful my parents were mostly
that's my parents yeah mom's but
speaking of interesting parents your
upbringing you had a and absolutely
incredible and I I mean just origin
story like you have seen and done it all
I mean the circumstances of your of your
growing up was was extremely harsh no
yeah it was pretty gnarly man you're
from Maryland my Maryland originally
place in Maryland
see here's the crazy thing so the way
Maryland is is it's like anywhere in the
world there's good places and there's
bad places and where I lived you know
you it's like Oh suburban beautiful area
and then you go a couple miles down and
take a left and it's like you don't want
to walk down here you know yeah but I
always say even much more than just your
neighborhood is also where you lived you
know I mean and so it like I said in my
house in my apartment like the gnarliest
[ __ ] was going on but even in the
building you know there was people who
like would rent various apartments and
in this
in this apartment they were cooking
crack and this apartment they were
pimping out prostitutes
in this apartment they were selling the
the the narcotics and this and knowing
that all this is happening and seeing it
and being invited and like you're like
eight years old and you're like crack
it's like it's pretty pretty gnarly but
I never you know even though I went
through a lot of messed up stuff even
when I was young I always knew it wasn't
right it wasn't like a like I've said
that I've done dumb [ __ ] I've shot guns
I've run around with knives I've done
all types of crazy [ __ ] but nothing I
can ever look in the mirror and like
regret you know what I mean like nothing
like that but yeah it was really
difficult but I just never focused on it
I always focused on how to get out and
for me it was music and I always looked
at um I never looked at it like oh yeah
[ __ ] and hoes and boats like I'm just
gonna like be a rapper I always say
persistence determination and realism
realism persistence determination
realism and wanting success more than
your next breath like that's how you can
get there and some people say oh it's
not realistic to be a rapper but I never
looked at it as that I looked at it as a
business mm-hmm and if I could market
and brand myself a certain way like
Teddy French then you know people would
want to buy into that brand but the
thing that I didn't want to create was a
brand that was built on fallacy so I was
like all right well you know what I'm
gonna be myself to the utmost degree and
it's either gonna work or it's not gonna
work and it's [ __ ] it's pretty doing
this isn't working it's do it okay yeah
so but you're both your parents when you
were growing up
yeah we're drug users is that correct
yeah yeah and alcoholic as well yeah so
tell your dad you've rekindled your
relationship with him recently yeah
definitely he's a good dude man he was
there was a point in his life when he
wasn't the best guy one of my earliest
memories was probably at 4 years old
being left in Southeast DC well he went
to go smoke crack with some chick that
wasn't my mom Jesus yeah I would have
preferred if they smoked crack together
yeah at least share the crack yeah I was
I was conceived out of wedlock 3 days
after they met oh my mom's best friends
Flor apparently leave it up to my dad to
tell you that yeah he's like son I have
something I wanted
yeah so they were never really together
but nice I saw your dad and I think it
was like an MTV interview and he seems
like your biggest fan
no usually he had the Rat Pack dad on
yeah the one of your album cover shirts
yeah all decked out he's a good dude and
what I've realized seems smart and
thoughtful yeah he there was just a time
when cuz like my dad has stolen my
identity and like created credit cards
with them he's Wow you know yeah like
when I was a child when I was 10 years
old he cuz we had the same name so my
name is Sir Robert Bryson second but his
name is Robert Bryson hall and so I
guess that's one reason that yeah but
there's a name yeah there's a there's a
million and one things that he did
negatively but what I would like to talk
about is deposited yeah and there was a
time in my in my life when you know he
kind of did me so wrong I stopped
talking to him and then he like showed
up at the signing I had out of nowhere
and which was really weird and I
basically told him I never wanted to see
him again and that the next time I would
see him would be at his funeral which is
[ __ ] up but it was but it was honest
because of what he's done and I was like
I've given you a million chances and
he's like I just won a million and one
and I was like no and so years I didn't
talk to him and I thought about it about
a year ago and I was like you know what
it's not that I'm angry at my dad it's
that I don't want to be hurt I said I
don't want to open up this door and his
vulnerability to be hurt again and I
really thought about it and I was like
sixty year old me is much wiser and
would probably still want to do
everything that he can to have some sort
of relationship with this man while he's
still here so even though I might not be
wise enough to do it I'm gonna do my
best but I'm gonna lay down ground rules
and I was like don't ask me for sure
there was a time my dad asked me for
eight hundred thousand dollars to buy
him a studio well I gotta work here you
got a you got a creep in a little more
subtle yeah
a couple hundred groceries so where's
things there's things I've I've just
learned like my dad is he's my dad and
he's kind of like a really cool uncle
you know who lets you do [ __ ] you
shouldn't do or talk to you about [ __ ]
he doesn't do like my dad steals my weed
like that's funny it's hilarious but I I
set ground rules and I was like don't
ask me for [ __ ] you know there's certain
members of my family I just don't talk
to you cuz they asked me for a bunch of
stuff or they wanted things for me I'm
like I don't want to talk about them if
we're gonna have a relationship it's
about me and you here and so I laid that
down and it's been uh it's been really
good he just got married
mmm with a blue tooth in his ear my dad
wears a blue tooth oh that's good that's
dad as [ __ ] yes however my mother last
time I talked to my mom was on my 21st
birthday and yeah so that was like a
while ago and I called her because my
sister called me crying and she was like
mommy says that that you don't talk to
her because of me and and I was like
what that's [ __ ] up that doesn't make
any sense and I called her and I
basically said mom the reason I don't
talk to you and I hadn't seen her since
I was 18 I said the reason I don't talk
to you is because it's your way or the
highway my mother's a type of person
who's like she's super religious and
she's like don't take the Lord's name in
vain
god damn it [ __ ] [ __ ] like
that is my mother so it's like it's a
very like hypocritical and I was raised
my whole life this way you know to the
point where like you know I was raised
Christian my whole life and then oh you
know her best friend of 20 years just
convinced her to be Catholic so now
we're Catholic for like two months until
they get into argument and then we go
back to being so so sincerity yeah but
it was she judged she judged people with
like super hardcore and I'm not here to
bash my mother I'm just here to give I'm
just explaining why I don't have
relationship with her and she's just the
type of person that it like I said it's
her way or the highway from religion to
life to this to that and but it's like
you know I remember when I was 14 I was
still a virgin it was ninth grade and I
had condoms in my backpack and I didn't
really like me I'm not the type of
person who has sex with a bunch of women
there's just not me like that's gross
like I have to I have to have some
connection you know in a relationship to
somebody even
back then as a kid so but anyway I had
these condoms and and she found them and
she was like are we gonna talk about you
know what I found in your backpack and I
was like what are you talking about she
was like condoms and I was like well I'm
not having sex and she was like well you
shouldn't have condoms and I was like
but what if something happens and she's
like well you just don't have sex and
I'm just kind of like that's not
realistic man you know like wouldn't you
prefer I'd be safe about it and smart
about it so it was with that along with
you know the alcoholism and you know she
took me out at school to home-school me
for three years and she didn't teach me
anything because she drank all night and
slept all day and I was alone and that's
when I super got on skateboarding and I
don't know though yeah and the fucked-up
part is so my mother unfortunately you
know she had dealt with she'd been raped
sexually assaulted her entire life
molested as a child and these are things
that [ __ ] with you now you take that
Plus drug use from LSD to you know
alcohol in general then antidepressants
but mixing antidepressants with alcohol
it's the gnarliest [ __ ] so it's like you
have a tortured soul here but also the
gnarliest part is my mom's [ __ ]
racist I know I've heard you telling
talking about and it talks about how
your mom is racist yeah like my mom that
I find just completely almost
fascinating I'm comfortable times a week
my mother called me a [ __ ] the cranes
not [ __ ] ever so you know all of her
children are from black men but yeah but
it's systemic you know she told me a
story about how when she was a teenager
of 13 14 years old she brought a young
black man you know she was dating a
young black man and her parents were
like no like you know there's no way
that you guys can be together and blah
blah blah and it's just really messed
her up because she's she genuinely was
attracted to you know strong beautiful
black men and but just society it's just
it's just it's it's something that I've
had people be like oh that doesn't even
sound right like you're lying that
doesn't make sense but it's like okay
whatever imagine growing up and it
doesn't make any sense
oh and definitely yeah it does make
sense in a way I mean it fits the
character you're describing of the whole
package of yeah it was first it was
really gnarly and the thing that hurt
the most I think is when I you know 15
16 years old first start got first
started getting into rap and hip-hop
using that as a form of expression to be
like life is hard
sometimes it's hard dealing with this
[ __ ] and she'd be like [ __ ]
don't you curse and then I'm just like
oh my god it's just such a brain it's
just [ __ ] yeah it's not it's so it
was so gnarly but once again I'm not
here to bash this woman only paint the
picture I understand but it's a burn you
know but so yeah you had you have those
two sides of parenting do you feel like
parentless in a way I mean I know you're
in touch with your father but it doesn't
seem like yeah not my dad my dad it's
not the kind of relationship you would
want in a perfect world with your father
definitely yeah it is hard sometimes you
probably feel like you're taking care of
him more than the other way around
Oh every time really what you want to be
feeling as a son you don't want them to
nurture you yeah you want to be
vulnerable I have had some really great
people in my life like my godmother like
I just call her my brother but Mary Jo
and Bernie back in Maryland who I first
met when I was 14 and it's funny cuz Oh
Eddie's friend my my godmother told me I
didn't know I told her this she said
when you first came to me and we first
met you said listen my mom like my house
situation is really terrible it's really
messed up but please don't call social
services please and she said that I said
said that because I was like and I know
why is because I don't know what the
hell is out there yeah but I don't
better the devil you know exactly and I
remember that I like I mean I remember
windows being shattered by cinder blocks
like my mom throwing she like just the
gnarly [ __ ] and me crying as a small kid
like oh not the knowledge I've been
kidnapped I've been held hostage but
like took the craziest [ __ ] dude I've
seen and dealt with and I just always
knew it wasn't right I don't know how to
explain just knew it wasn't right I was
like hey this is not how you treat a
child this is not how you treat one
another and seeing my mother being
beaten and bloody and drunk and one of
my earliest earliest memories it's about
three and my mom was having some kind of
an argument but I was asleep and was
about three or four in the morning
and I woke up to the police raiding
knocking our door down and handcuffing
her and dragging her down these like
cobblestone stones from our townhouse in
her blood soaking the the sidewalk which
was so gnarly but I was like yeah that's
not right for sure it's it's it's pretty
insane but it's like damn it just seems
like pretty dark right now like no okay
it's fast I mean yeah listen we got to
go to a quick commercial guys we'll be
right back with logic I want to pick up
right where we work this is just
absolutely okay riveting oh thank you
too Bobby
we're gonna go pee you guys we'll be
right back insurance is one of those
topics that everyone knows a little bit
about but do you understand it well
enough to feel comfortable buying it
whether your insurance expert or newbie
policy genius has created a website that
makes it easy for you to compare quotes
get advice and get covered now before I
discover policy genius I was paying a
certain amount with a certain company
and I came on this website and compared
for auto insurance and I saved $100 a
month for the same coverage the same
exact everything with another company
and that's the power of policy genius
because there's so many different prices
on insurance from home insurance to life
insurance to audio shirts auto insurance
and whatever their shirts you can
imagine policy genius has got you
covered they get a check across the
board for all the companies that offer
it and make sure you're getting the
right price that's why it's the easy way
to get life insurance and anything else
under the moon and minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
the coverage you need at the price that
you can afford from there you just apply
online and the advisors advisors that
policy Jesus will handle all of the red
tape they'll even renegotiate your rate
with the insurance company no extra fees
or commissions sales agents just helpful
advice and personalized service and
policy Jesus doesn't even take make life
insurance easy whether you're shopping
for disability insurance or protect your
income homeowners your auto insurers
they can get you covered fast so no
matter how much or how little you know
about life insurance you can find the
right policy and minutes at policy
genius.com policy genius the way to
compare and buy all insurances under the
moon
quip you know what time it is put this
in your mouth and brush because your
breath is awful your gums are receding
you don't brush your mouth long enough
this is what this toothbrush does it
addresses all those problems and it's
packed into a tiny little vibrating tube
it's everything you need to keep your
mouth and your breath fresh cavity free
kissable and beautiful this is on
Oprah's oh-oh list okay GUP loves this
toothbrush and forget about those people
don't even care about them I endorse
this this is a toothbrush that I use now
let me tell you about this toothbrush
softest bristles in the game easy you
turn it on in fibrates phone and
pulsates when it tells you when it's
time to switch sides and it times you
and tells you when you're done brushing
to make sure you get that thorough
beautiful brush that you need every time
to keep your mouth beautiful and
kissable and fresh oral hygiene is the
most important thing in the world right
EULA yes last thing you want to do is
kiss some nasty mouth [ __ ] loser
don't let that be you okay that's right
whip is the one place and let me tell
you the best part about quip it starts
at just 25 bucks you want to get a
vibrating toothbrush on this level is
gonna cost you at least two thousand
dollars and uh the market or wherever
you buy that crap so that's why I love
quip guys let's give it a shot it's $25
just to start they're backed by twenty
thousand dental professionals they're
backed by me forget about the dentist
okay quip starts at just 25 dollars go
to get quip calm flush h3 right now and
you'll get your first refill pack for
free with a quip electric toothbrush
guys that's your first refill refill
pack for free at GE t qu yp.com / h3
give it a shot you're gonna love it
get quick calm /h three honey what do
you say about honey it's free money it's
really so simple it's an app that you
install on your browser and when you are
shopping online at all the major stores
Amazon Walmart Best Buy whatever it's
all covered it's going to clip all the
coupons like an old grandmother's got
your back and it's gonna make sure that
you're getting the best deals every time
you shop
honey saves me money every freaking time
there's no catch it's a free browser you
get in Bob's your uncle it's that easy
okay
I saved 30 bucks on Amazon the other day
just shopping for baby stuff I think we
bought like a we were buying so much
baby stuff behind but the total comes
out because it it compares prices on
Amazon because there's so many different
ways to buy and it intelligently
crunches the numbers and includes
shipping and all this stuff shows you
prices string make sure you're getting
the best deal crunch the numbers on all
this baby [ __ ] we bought $30 it saved me
for nothing I'm telling you honey must
have saved me a hundred of dollars since
I started using and it's effortless it's
free it takes two clicks to install guys
you be a fool not to dip your toes into
honey I know that sounds messy but trust
me it's great there's 10 million people
using honey right fricking now and honey
has over a hundred thousand five-star
reviews on the google chrome store but
again forget about them I give a
five-star review those hundred thousand
people could take a hike take it for me
Time magazine calls it basically free
money hey they still have for me
[ __ ] next time you're shopping on
Amazon don't wonder whether you found
the best deal just add honey and get the
best price automatically okay it's free
guys go to join honeycomb slash h3
that's join honey comp slash h3 okay
the smart shopping assistant that helps
you save time and money install it it's
a free app give it a shot for a week and
tell me you don't save a bunch of money
I do not care about clothing
I do not care about shopping I want to
look good and I don't want to put the
effort in right that's what most guys I
feel like feel like and girls I think a
lot of girls feel that way that's why a
stitch fix is such an incredible service
you go online you get an online personal
stylist okay you take a survey you tell
them what you like
he's on what you don't like you tell
them your budget and they go to work
putting together the beautiful perfect
outfit to fit your body whether you're
skinny little twink or a fat fat fat
oversized mama this fee being fed to
death by your significant other it
doesn't matter
they got space for everybody okay just
go to stitch fix calm /h Street you tell
them everything you like how much you
want to spend Bob's your uncle you'll be
paired with your very own personal
stylist who will hand pick items and
send them to your door you try them on
you pay only for what you love you
return the rest shipping exchanges it
returns are always free you're basically
trying on clothes in your living room
and then you send it back it's easy as
eating a piece of pie okay and let me
tell you that's easy there's no
subscription required you can sign up to
receive scheduled shipments or get your
fix whenever you want
styling fees are 20 bucks but guess what
it's applied towards anything you keep
from your shipment so it's virtually
fruit get started now as stitch fix calm
/ h3 and you'll get an extra 25% off
when you keep all the items in your box
that's stitch fixed calm / h3 to get
started a6 calm / h3 we are back with
logic and the beautiful and very
pregnant ela just a ship with our baby
Theater on it before we get back into it
I've got a video I want to get your
reaction on okay let's just watch okay
here we go
is there audio there should be I can't
tell if it's right or there's no audio
oh no I said doing the same thing hey
what happened
these things happen yeah okay there it
is there's no way hello I got to start
it over because there's the suspense is
important so for those who are listening
on audio it's just a man recording the
bathroom floor okay in a bathroom stall
actually probably hearing something I
think there is sound it's just a quiet
it's a quiet moment
you know dan is there sound I feel like
there's not sound I think you're right
come on Dan check something else Dan
Zach
Ian anybody the love of God is the sound
working I mean we tested it right before
we went so let's see yeah there's no
sound oh no there's no wait okay maybe
it's my fault they were come in and
check let's check this home what the
hell was that I know and now it's not I
know you blew it for everybody listening
so uh it was your sound down on the
computer yeah I muted it bro I came in a
muted it Oh when it got unplugged you
know what right before t1 live this is
the boys thunderstruck so here we go
what sound one more time here we go okay
well we got a crackle here so where were
we let's um well you can play it yeah
that's all yeah
you're doing so good no no this is good
it's real life bro so the people why I
can't do that crackle why wait listen
okay you guys did was spying on him
taking a [ __ ]
oh my god and I know this guy I don't
know if I'd be flattered or yeah there
should be flattered I've always been
someone I have friends to get a lot of
attention from gay men and I've always
been a little jealous of them I'm not
gonna be completely honest with you guys
yeah I'm like no gay guy has ever tried
to [ __ ] me and that's the real test of a
few tracks maybe you just weren't in gay
spots
I pin to so many gays I go hang out at
gay bars just do it come on Jesus no it
doesn't happen but definitely some
element of being flattered but the guy
must have seen him laying on the floor
there put on his camera and I love how
casual he is why on the floor mm-hmm
sorry what imagine like what would you
do if there haven't you like legit what
would you do I first of all I wouldn't
be a spook than that guy I don't know
what well I don't know i wouldnt have
the presence of mind to film it I would
just yeah me neither freak I'd be like
what the hell are you doing I'd be like
why are you doing this excuse hello yeah
I don't know it's but imagine why I
don't know why that guy thought he won't
be able to see him yeah and he's a he's
in a suit and a tie so he's kind of
somewhat pretty right would like be
willing to just lay on the lake floor
like that cuz he wanted to see this dude
taking a [ __ ] so bad is there any is
there like a is there any like backstory
have now found out with madness is all
it is this is all you get
well somebody's got to be able to
identify this maybe the people who are
doing all those Taylor Swift face motion
yeah dude
have you been deep faked no no that I
doubt not that I'm aware of is that kind
of a flattering thing okay I don't know
it's kind of a weird thing
Neela's been deep faked really did I
know there's a deep fake of you in very
this at me it's like like taking dick I
mean oh be frank with you and it's
pretty gnarly you if you type Eva Klein
don't gets loud I just fine I'm more I'm
fascinated I'm just this someone would
spend their time doing that is
incredible just watch the porn yeah
exactly you know that is but not as
where does this
[Laughter]
it's not like it wasn't the first time
but it's funny cuz yeah like he's
annoyed like he's upset he's like God or
the guy laying down I think it was the
guy on the [ __ ] said sorry sorry man
well I gonna have to put an end to this
why would you do you're predator right
sorry man it's in today so it what I can
piece together is that this wasn't the
first time I feel like this guy comes in
after him every time and legs on the
floor I wonder if in his mind he was
like he's into it he goes in there takes
[ __ ] and I lay on the floor that's how
we do it I creep on Reddit I creep
what's your subreddit where do you [ __ ]
around I love better every loop I love
that one I love the Red Dead Redemption
- I'm always on Oh for real yeah I love
that man I tried getting in that game so
I actually didn't try that hard I bought
it I played for 30 minutes and it's just
like all this no no you gotta do this no
don't trust me dude you get through the
snow and then it gets really great
really I still didn't beat it cuz I've
been so damn busy but I started playing
super meatboy again oh I love that such
a you know that's like in my opinion the
perfect video game simple addictive
great controls compelling good it's like
ma I really want to do a video game I
was talking to my art director one that
I brought about it I think it'd be
pretty cool so I have these ideas mm-hmm
it'd be sick but not like if it's like
100 million dollar video game like I
want it to be like Super Mario Bros on
acid the best games are indeed come on
yeah
listen let's be serious here it's have
you played a cup head yes yeah but not
on my xbox yeah I said I can't be this
too hard all right I think I got pretty
deep I was playing with ela but I think
the skill the skill gap got too extreme
I loved the art and I wanted to play the
game cuz I love how it looks but it's
too hard and I got it it's insane but
that's kind of what makes it great yeah
that's right I mean because dude old
games used to punish you
yeah like you could only beat old games
if you were mental yeah you had a snap
you know how to do it all the time you
had to be like a Rain Man here this this
is the sequel to the first video okay oh
my god wait you gotta watch that again
can you not autoplay YouTube Christ
let's get back this is you by the way
pretty cool the link to inception it's
pretty it's pretty late that's good see
that's in case I like flip out and punch
me in the face
no no yeah I don't think we'd be able to
correct anything true I wish there was
some but you can read the comments
peeping creep can you ask about a post
Malone collab post even one people know
one apparently alright let's not get to
inception yeah back it up
Mexican crawls the guys what if he's
like Salvadorian yeah he could be that's
true that's very true
and so there you go that's my series
come Abby bro yeah it's pretty pretty
gnarly so tell me about the fact and I
love this you hadn't do not have social
media on your phone
I don't yeah it's it's like I said it's
very bittersweet let me just sip this
please hydrate we tried it for like a
week were you but it erased it it's so
hard to keep that I erase it and then I
had Eva checking it for yeah I feel like
it may it must be even harder with you
guys because you know it's such a core
like direct to write a job yeah it
really is and I feel like for me it
really was a part of the job I think for
any up-and-coming artist it is and I'm
just not enough incoming artists anymore
mm-hmm and because of that so many
people are aware you don't need it
really anymore yeah it's like I want it
though like I want to be able to cuz it
used to be a safe haven it used to be a
place that I could go to and people
could genuinely have like conversations
now it's like if you drop a song first
of all anything that's new people like
freaked out about it like it doesn't
matter what it is like I remember astral
world came out and I love that album and
there was all these people's like it's
not as good as rodeo lovable and then
and then it becomes this huge thing and
everybody loves it I liked it out the
gate but it's like that's that's the
world we live in now everybody feels
like they write for Rolling Stone who
has a Twitter account they feel they
feel the need to say something and I
feel like people more so enjoy pointing
out the things they don't like but it's
sickening because we as you know the
artists and the creatives are drawn to
the negativity for example you know if I
did a post and it had a million likes on
Instagram or something but it had 30,000
or 50,000 comments but out of those
50,000 maybe 5,000 were like truly
negative comments one it's like why am I
so focused on this loud minority that's
the gnarly part about it because dude
there's a million people who liked it
and didn't even have to say [ __ ] about
it but it's just it's though it's the
feeling and the wanting of acceptance
but that was a big dark place for me
that's why I got off it because it was
making me depressed every time I went on
social media it was a truly negative
experience of like you suck or you're
whack or you're this sea or that or just
so many negative things
zulan you know I've heard it described I
think Jordan Pearson I asked him why do
we or maybe it was my therapist I don't
remember but I said why do why is it
that we focus on these negative ones and
it was described to me as it's an
evolutionary being where you want to
identify the danger and you want to
identify the wink points in your
character where the danger or the
criticism is yeah because that's the
stuff that puts you at risk so from an
evolutionary standpoint you were you are
those are the things you are trying to
again that's insane about you right so
yeah there's kind of an explanation for
why we seek those out yeah but it's but
see that stuff doesn't serve us well
anymore but so many times I'm not even
kidding like 99% of the times that I
either investigate it or have like said
something cuz that's the net that's the
part that also sucked is like I never
did it really bad but somebody could
hate on me they could say something like
like I had like a funny line about
fortnight and this in this last song I
did Keanu Reeves and I'm like I don't
play enough games that's we talking for
at night it's just like a funny it's a
not a big deal and a year ago I had like
kind of teased the song and everybody
was like oh this is crazy that for
nightline blah blah and it actually
didn't come out till a year later and
then you have all these people like all
I turned it off after the fortnight and
that's like I think that is so idiot
first of all we all know you didn't turn
it off you played it a thousand times
yeah okay but it's night it's just it's
just so funny that people just want to
like cling on to these dislike negative
stuff it's really odd to me well and
also an important distinction for myself
when thinking about these stuff is that
these are people having a conversation
about you not with you yeah you know how
you talk about people when they're not
in the room you say stuff that you don't
necessarily mean of course you say stuff
that you would never say to them you say
stuff that you would be so embarrassed
and politic Batchelor right I'm gonna be
honest guilty pleasure I need to watch
the bad why you would love it I love it
took me so I'm so into reality but do
you want a fiance 90-day fiance
bro that's the trash the real [ __ ]
really okay I have to check out two
hours long bro oh my god my point is is
like
I rip those girls apart I'm like in my
bed I'm like this chicks [ __ ] crazy
this chick like I don't exactly like you
you say these things but they're not
like I would never actually she was in
the room never do that here's the thing
I would never tweet something like that
like even take like a Glock out of it I
wouldn't I'm not the type of person who
would open my phone well at that person
and be like you're psycho I think those
first of all that's because you're
you're sane and well-adjusted
I mean you know relatively I'll say the
same for myself but these are people
that don't ever expect that you would
actually read that now here's the gnarly
[ __ ] and this is why I don't respond
because I've done it in the past and
somebody will say something like that
for Nightline in the limo so turbo blah
blah blah and I was like I wrote that
line because I thought for tonight was
kind of fun and I was a year ago you
were playing for tonight yeah and so I
so I just said the line would you rather
me rap about something that I don't like
and that isn't myself and they're like
yeah that makes so much sense hey bro
can have some tickets usually but like
it's always so it's very it's very like
the there's the 1% that will stick to
their guns and be like [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] like yeah it's pretty rare but
I've yet to ever have like anybody like
in my face say some [ __ ] because it's
the thing is everybody knows I can rap
and everybody knows their substance and
my music and I talk about [ __ ] from the
heart it just is what it like you can't
you could be like oh that you know that
Keanu Reeves like somebody tried to say
it was a glorified mumble rap and I'm
like this is hilarious like that we're
just in this place where people but they
have their own opinions and what I've
learned is is it's art like back in the
day you know you'd have kings and sorry
I keep feeling like I'm only talking to
him but it's good but there's like um
there's you know there was kings in the
like Renaissance and all this that would
Commission these artists and some of
these artists would paint like you know
men having sex or or women together or
this or this these things that these
artists would be murdered over hmm and
it's kind of no different today as far
as social media and just in general like
your art is not yours anymore when you
release it it's just yeah it's just not
yours and at the end of the day you know
this loud minority could say things like
oh it's not the same or it's not that
this or it's not that and it's like well
then stop listening to my music
stop coming to my concerts stop giving
me millions of dollars and buying my
merchandise stop doing all these things
but the thing is is those aren't really
the people who are or not or not that's
the thing yeah another thing that I kind
of accepted is that no matter who you
are or what you're doing when it gets to
a certain scale there's just a
statistical inevitability that there's
only a certain amount of people they're
gonna hate you and not like what you're
doing yeah so if everybody loves you
first of all that's impossible
but when you get to a certain scale
there's gonna be people that are
contrary n' I mean that's all it is
there's every carryin one of the
gnarliest things I think I ever saw on
the Internet was a comment for Kendrick
Lamar's humbly mm-hmm and he says what
did you say like show me something real
or something like ass with some stretch
month out the photos yeah without the
Photoshop yeah and so I love that line
because basically saying like yo like ya
real natural women sure some women look
like goddesses but you know there's
other women who you know just got it a
little thick and they got some stretch
marks or what it is and he's like I
don't want the fake I want the real I
don't want the facade and so I saw some
comment that was like how dare you with
your sexual fetishes of stretch marks
and your objectifying you can't say
anything so it's a I think honestly
being off social media is the right play
because it's just it's and I think I'm
happy what you're tapping into yeah
we're it applies to normal people at
almost as much because dude when
everything on social media is so
depressing oh my god on Instagram
everybody looks I know this is like a a
well-trodden comment but it's so true
that everybody you see them at their
best you see them at their happiest you
see them with their best clothes on
vacation in front of a mural with their
friends wait for my album you know what
I'm saying
yeah it sounds really you know I get I
start I find myself thinking a lot about
it because we're gonna have a kid and
now kids have smartphones like from a
really young age and I wonder like I see
how it affects us and we're adults yeah
and we in it really affects us I want
what is it like for a kids changing
their brain yeah but that's the other
thing is I was looking at other artists
years ago not not as of recently but I
was looking like to him like how come he
gets more likes how come he gets this
how come I'm you know I'm selling out
shows way bigger than him or this or
that and it becomes this like nasty
thing what a trite well yeah and now I'm
like man anybody who's winning I don't
give a damn who you are I don't care the
type of music like if you're talking
about like [ __ ] and hoes it's like
hey man nobody's at the club like you
know [ __ ] listening to you know NAS
is illmatic like in the club like we
listen to NAS because we want to you
know provoke our thoughts and like
really digest that [ __ ] with like a you
know bomb we'd strain but like when
you're in the club like yeah you want to
listen to post you want to listen to you
know whoever's popping like that's what
you want and there's a time in place for
it
but also there's this this this negative
way of thinking cuz you know like I'm
excited I'm working on the soundtrack
now for my novel and it's all like it's
hard to explain it's like a it's
definitely like some indie [ __ ] it's
like Indian singing and it's really it's
really awesome and it's a story of love
about shredder about just the main
character and how he falls in love with
this woman and all this other stuff
whatever and if we're talking about
super Marcus super Marcia talked about
that and I novel yeah when I was young I
was like yo singing is wack like if you
sing it on your track like that [ __ ] is
garbage son like this is me at like 17
years old and I couldn't sing at all and
as I got older like I said I wanted to
challenge myself not just doing rap
album after rap album I like I want to
do different things and I want to grow
and so I started you know singing and
and and doing different things but the
funny thing is there is no [ __ ] way
that's somebody anybody would be like
you'll sing in his garbage if they had a
voice like Adele right but they're
listening to like the most underground
hip-hop are they really gonna say I'm
not gonna sing like an angel because
that shit's whack yeah but it's just
these people that are so in their own
box in their own thing you know it's the
same [ __ ] like when Drake came out
everybody was clowning him for singing
mm-hmm I was clowning I was like what is
this and then I'm like oh [ __ ] it's the
best I ever had like you
because I was just so underground and
idiotic and like Drake inspires me to
you know be a better artist so it's
pretty funny but yeah the book
supermarket is a novel that's coming out
actually have the date here in March
yeah March some I forgot you've you've
written a 26 the March this is what I
call you a Renaissance man in the
beginning because thank you you are an
artist you're a musician but you've just
you're about to release a book which is
on pre-order you can pre-order an Amazon
supermarket and you also are working on
a movie you told me about yes you are
you are everywhere man you are
hardworking individual thank you so tell
me about the process of making a book
because that is just a completely
different medium from what you're used
to working on uh well I was reading like
I always hated reading just because of
the school system and just how they like
they just they just made it this totally
unappealing experience you're right like
you have to do this or you have to do
whatever yeah and I just wasn't with it
and I never enjoyed it and so when I was
like 25 years old that's the first time
I really decided to like read a book hmm
and I don't know why but I picked these
Indiana Jones novels I guess because
it's like I've seen the movies I can
relate I can see this character in my
head so I read like eight of them and
then I'm reading like hg wells time
machine and all these other different
novels and I got into a ready player one
by Ernest Cline was more my favorite
books of all I love it and he's become a
good friend and mentor of mine he's a
bomb and I was like you know what I'm a
red book and my buddy Christian who's in
the other room
who's my day-to-day manager [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's like he was like you can't
write a put bro and I was like yeah I
can't easily get his red book cause you
read both for a week yes I can and then
I did well that's a yeah most of us I'll
read a book for a week I'm like I'm
gonna write a [ __ ] burn yeah but then
I forget about it
maybe that's the difference between me
and you man I was just driven I was
excited and I honestly him telling me
that like actually kind of lit a fire
under my ass right but no I mean I was
going through a lot of [ __ ] man like a
lot of [ __ ] and and the book it's so
weird it's hard to kind of explain what
it is like I did my best with my editor
Stewart I
Simon & Schuster to create like a just a
just a brief paragraph on kind of what
the the book is about but it's basically
about this guy who deals with insane
anxiety and depression and loss and it's
I just it's so weird because it's like
how do you promote a book without giving
it away mm-hmm because it's like very
important it's sci-fi so it's like
sci-fi but it's it's it's I mean if it
it takes place in the most mundane place
ever in a supermarket but I wrote half
of it I wrote the first half of it when
I was at my probably lowest point when
it came to anxiety and so much of the
book is like with the exception of you
know hallucinations and gnarly [ __ ] like
that it is what I was experiencing and I
just but I put it in this fictional
place and then I stopped writing it for
two years and the second half of the
book actually takes place two years
later and then he's in a much better
place where I found myself mm-hm and so
by the time I like you know hit the hand
it was like very emotional because I was
like I'm a totally different person as
is my character and it's also about it's
I mean this isn't a big deal but it's
about a guy who's writing a book for the
first time so that allowed me to kind of
get away with a lot of [ __ ] and just say
you know who gives a damn and there are
moments when I think like man you know
there's there's like the the highbrow
you know establishment of people who
that are gonna read this book and be
like oh but I didn't write it for them I
wrote it for myself I wrote it to vent
and I wrote it for honestly I wrote it
for not just young people but all people
who don't give a [ __ ] about books and I
wrote it in a very just fun way where
you can go through this this entire
experience and this this story and enjoy
it it's like full of like sex and murder
and you know drugs and all this cool
[ __ ] you know that it's like yeah it's
really it's really fun and I you said
you were inspired by Quentin Tarantino
oh yeah and that's that's a very Quinton
Tarantino line oh yeah where he's like
it's when he gets approached by like
really nasty I some be interviewed by
this like old Christian lady and she's
like do you really think that young
people should be watching your video v's
she was talking about Kill Bill he's
like
yeah it's got a murder he's like it's
fun chanted he's such a legend I know JJ
Abrams was telling me about him I gotta
say James gotta say the mold name yeah
my buddy you gotta let him know
uh Nobby hehe he was I was like man he's
so like awesome is he that cool in
person he's like yo he's even bet he's
oh yeah you'll meet him I was like what
you'll meet him and I was like it didn't
pop fiction was one of my first movies
that I like I fell in love with yeah
mine was killed bill that's how I
discovered hip hop did you know that
that's so strange
yeah I mean that's really so the RZA
made the sound trade the soundtrack and
I didn't know who the hell RZA was but I
knew wu-tang clan we all know what an
clan you know and then I found out that
RZA was in whoo tang clan and I
discovered wu-tang and then through that
I got all their individual albums and I
got only built 4 Cuban Linx by Raekwon
the chef and nas was on that and that's
how I truly discovered all new houses
music and then from there it's a it was
a rap but yeah it's all cuz of Terrance
you know who I still have I can't
believe it tell me who are your favorite
hip-hop artists currently or currently
and and seriously No - yeah man well I
love Kendrick I love Drake I love Cole
those those guys are just like just a
plethora yeah I loved Travis is super
fun but you know I came up on Big Daddy
Kane and Big L and as I've said before
Tribe Called Quest and you know Biggie
and but even dilated peoples and
Jurassic 5 and like all the super
underground fun [ __ ] yeah I mean there's
there's so many especially the roots oh
my god Black Thought yeah from the roots
is like to me just you perform with a
great at all yes have been strange I was
that's why I did it twice the first time
I was like freaking out there's these
moments my buddy told me about that that
I don't have many more of and it's
nervous like true to form oh my god I'm
gonna throw up and the last one so it
was when I did Jimmy Fallon so it's like
oh my god I'm performing in front of 9
million people with
like don't mess this up so I did that
and then what else the Grammys was a
huge one just being there did that show
was wild that was a wonderful you had an
awesome one on Jimmy Kimmel - right yeah
everybody yeah oh yeah I did a black
spider-man
that was so fun I was walking down I'm
saying the part of blacks by the way
black spider-man came to fruition good
do you feel like you can kind of take
credit for that well it's funny before
everybody's in the comments Miles
Morales is but no I meant like when I
was saying that I meant like a black
Peter Parker like walk am Peter Parker
be bright and yeah but into this
spider-man you got you got um halfway
there we didn't get a black Peter Park
half black way there ya know that was
fun and then meeting a man damn right
yeah I wanted to talk about bro so first
of all so you recently performed with
Eminem in Hawaii - a huge how many
people were in the ATM I don't know it
was a lot as a state line I was like 30
to 50,000 yeah insane amounts yeah
first of all tell me what is meeting
Eminem mean to you I mean was that so
much listen - I haven't been like
there's yes of course
like he's one he's the first rap verse I
ever memorized on forgot about Dre hmm
and you know I was so young I remember
my sister took two sides of a tape this
is I'm dating myself right now but the
you know these old cassette tapes and
she had it on each side of it that she
had done for me and dude I mean it's
Eminem bro you know what I mean it's
like the goat yeah so really I was
excited that he first and foremost had
invited me to come do the show out of
that is really come through it's a long
story it's a long story it's like we got
time if you don't want to say I can't
explain but it was very cool that's all
I said I get this invite from him that's
amazing yeah that recognition from
really the highest place insane so we're
in Hawaii and I'm there and I was just
like really stoked and I know I'm gonna
meet him and I but the whole time I was
like cool like whatever like it's all
good like yeah this is cool and even in
the stadium like I wasn't really nervous
about the fact that I'm in a stadium I
was just excited it was my first time
performing in Hawaii I've always wanted
perform
never had so I was just excited and then
I didn't realize the magnitude of [ __ ]
until you know his security guards tell
my security guys tell me that it's time
and so it's like a seven minute trek
through this stadium am i getting like a
car and I go through all the gnarly [ __ ]
and we get we walked there and I'm there
with Paul Rosenberg who's over at Def
Jam he's the president Def Jam and he's
his his manager so I don't know if you
remember those old the the first songs
he would do and he would like Paul would
call him like you can't say this crazy
ass [ __ ] and that was him so we're there
and he walks me backstage and who did I
see first I'm trying to remember
I think alchemist came out so Alchemist
is an incredible producer he's also a
super ill spitter and he's Eminem's
deejay and he's just like I mean he's
worked with everybody's been around
everybody primo and and Dilla and I mean
just a huge staple and hip-hop for me
and for many others and so he was super
cool as [ __ ] and then I saw Royce two
five nine and Royce me and him are
homies so seeing him made me a lot more
comfortable which was really awesome and
then and then mr. Porter was there and
he was super cool I didn't know I was
like I never met this guy and he was
just like so just cool and open and nice
and then having a game and Eminem comes
out of [ __ ] hoodie wrapkin in a
napkin knows super [ __ ] cool man just
like so he's like hey what's up I'm
nervous and I'm like hey I'm [ __ ]
nervous
like I just let him know I'm like yo you
guys if I'm being weird this is a big
deal for me and I was like look I get it
and I wasn't trying to sound like I
didn't like say this because I don't
want to sound like an [ __ ] but it's
like I know what it's like when people
are nervous to meet me you know and
they're like shaking crying [ __ ] and but
I get it I'm always cool about it but I
didn't want to come off that way but I
also didn't want to come off just in
genuine like sup yeah nice to meet ya
yeah what's up Marshall I was like I was
genuine I was just like dude if I seem a
little weird or a little red in the face
it's cuz I may be on
like I'm so happy to be here with well
I'll say I saw you kind of gushing on I
could tell you was so excited I think
it's good it's such a meaningful
experience and you were very expressive
about that I think that's very cool yeah
it had to be so honest but the cool
thing like I've met a lot of people and
they've so many of them have been
insanely cool and they invite you in a
sec hey what's up and you guys just kind
of talk for a while and then you know if
they want because I'm not big on
pictures mm I I don't want to invade
anybody space I don't want somebody to
think I'm there for a picture but it
typically tends to benefit both parties
if you guys take a picture and post it
on Instagram because everybody gets
excited that you're together but they
were like we want a picture and I was
like oh my god that's so cool and so you
know we took a picture but the biggest
thing was just talking hip-hop we talked
about freestyles versus writtens versus
like the arrow we're in and the time and
the [ __ ] you could say and the [ __ ] you
can't say and he's like I just say but
you know but it's just like all this
stuff it was it was a really special
special experience and I won't really
get into what we talked about because
it's a it's a memory for me yeah you
know and it was it was really spot
everybody it wasn't just em and it was
mr. Porter and Royce and Paul and an
alchemist they were all just so kind and
it I mean we were chilled like 20
minutes that's awesome like I had to go
to the stage you know and it was it was
it was an incredible experience I'll
always cherish and he's a really good
dude man and he just loves rap right he
just loves rap yeah you can tell yeah
it's incredible
damn yeah that's awesome pretty sick I'm
glad you had that experience me too it
was it was a well actually you were
supposed to come on the podcast last
week that's why I can it was a big day
and you're like hey man I heard from Dan
from your manager yeah yeah he's like Oh
mm invited him to do a show in Hawaii
and I was like that mother to blow me up
yeah it's pretty but I wasn't even like
I'm at [ __ ] jay-z and beyonce bro
yeah and they were super cool they were
like they're like royalty it was weird
they way I can say did they look did
that that or of like guilty they walked
in like slow motion like you know
there's like 90
like the white girl walks in it's like
oh my god it's Jenna
right yeah that was jay-z and Beyonce
that's why but Eminem it was it was like
I was different but I was also bombarded
by jay-z and Beyonce I was in New York
at this spot called legacy records which
I love to go not to flex but I was at
Jerry Seinfeld's house oh that's a flood
yes look something like and his wife was
like you gotta try this spot and I was I
really rhyme Phil's house yeah back it
up in in Manhattan where does he live
don't give me the address yeah yeah yeah
he's in the city but the wild part is he
wasn't there so I met him in Vegas I met
him in Vegas and he was so there was
literally nobody there he just walks in
he's like oh my god he knew you yeah he
knew me because of his wife well they'd
saw my professor fin yeah she's super
cool Oh and so but their daughter as
well Sasha who's really sweet and so
they saw me on the Grammys when I
basically was like all these countries
aren't [ __ ] holes and oh sure oh she's
ready
and yeah they were super cool and then
they he was supposed to be there but he
had a gig and I was like oh I don't give
a [ __ ] I just wanna hang out with you
guys you guys seem super cool so I went
to their house and we all just hung out
and like got food and then she told me
about this spot called legacy records
his wife so we went to legacy records a
restaurant yeah it's like a restaurant
lounge bar it's like really cool it
sounds super bougie but it's like very
chill it's not weird and so we go and I
go a couple times and then I so this is
one of the later times that I was there
for some I forget what anyway and we're
just chilling and in [ __ ] walks jay-z
and we hear that the door opened we hear
that we hear that jay-z was like next
door and I was like oh that's cool but
he's probably not gonna come over here
like no biggie
and then Pepe my security guard walks
over and he goes like this
and he shows the rockefeller diamond so
I guess I wasn't as nervous for that
because I didn't really know his ID on
me
like a sudden thing but with Eminem it
was like his probably was one of the
nerd most new build up but the crazy
[ __ ] is is I was so nervous when I met
em but by the time I left it felt like a
friend now that was so cool like it
wasn't it wasn't weird yeah
Jerry Seinfeld's and and Larry David
yeah our what's Jerry's Jerry's like a
billionaire was his house [ __ ] out of
this world
it was insane wasn't Matta but I only
saw like two storeys of it so you know
I'm pretty sure he's got like a five
story yeah he's got a building it was
cool man
I mean not to like give the details of
his house away so he was the in breath
it was Jerry's got it on lockdown
what's it what is it what's his Simpsons
address six something yes Evergreen
Terrace no no it was super cool though
it was really sweet it was really nice
it was cool his wife loves to cook yeah
see on it I follow on Instagram yeah
she's like this she's like so cool yeah
you got to be a special character I feel
like to marry Jerry Seinfeld yeah anyway
I got some fan questions all right and
there there's some really good ones here
so you know I was biracial I was there
there were a couple of those
I made the editorial decision not to ask
so this one comes from yourselves and he
asks hi Bobby and Ethan I went to
gatorsburg high school okay let's say
that right gatorsburg Gaithersburg high
school a few years ago and I'm a huge
fan of both you my question is to both
you how does the balance between luck
and hard work factor in to your success
how does look play into having a hit
song or a viral video you built very
successful in the ways that some people
claim requires luck it's my belief that
no matter how hard you work at least
some luck is required because there are
so many people that will work very hard
and still not make it actually I've
thought about this and the truth is that
there's always luck and success but luck
is the outcome of like resilience and
dedication hard work the luck that I
consider in my life was being born
in America you know my the luck that I
consider my life is the happenstance of
meeting ela which mole good things came
in my life at the Holocaust Museum at
the but like if I didn't meet ela
there's no way I don't think that in a
parallel universe that I would be an
entertainer right because well you guys
know the story so the luck in my life I
consider to be the things that were
completely out of my control that I was
just so fortunate to have these
opportunities to be born in America with
opportunity to meet ela you know to go
on this trip to Israel and all there's
so many opportunities for those that
path to be diverged in a different
direction but I was so fortunate that by
spite that's just a pure cosmic luck
that the path led to you and everything
came from that so oh my god but in terms
of like the hard work and the dedication
and the being on a mission to succeed at
what we're doing that I don't think was
I don't think about that as well yeah
that was we worked for years and years
and years before anyone care to watched
our videos or [ __ ] we made [ __ ] for a
long time but we just stayed focused
because that's what we wanted to do you
know like sorry that's it that's not no
it's I you know how many songs I have
and there's you know there's fans who
know that I have all these songs but the
reason they never came out is because
it's like there's no footage of Jordan
in the gym missing you know to me and
it's like for me yeah you can call it
luck I moreso see it as like energy you
know it's just weird I'm yeah the energy
man you know II think but for me I
worked every single day yeah every
single day on music and raps and rhymes
in production like I made it my entire
life there was no way that something was
not going to come from it just right
there was nothing else and I think
that's a you know there's a not to plug
somebody else's book but it's a book
called Think and Grow Rich and there's
basically this this quote unquote secret
to success but I don't think it's a
secret I think it's very
simple it's very easy and I've already
said a persistence determination realism
and wanting success more than your next
breath right and I think the truth of
the matter is that you cannot read a
book and then be like oh it's is you
have it you have that right yeah you
know what if you can't teach it
yeah and learn it you you know there's
no book that's gonna tell you you just
you have it and you're gonna get it or
you're not because this person's point
is some people work really hard and they
don't make it and I mean but it's like
it's not I need to see really really
hard I something will come out of it but
you also have to be good because if
you're working really hard that means
that you're good so is that I guess
that's luck you know yeah I guess it's
luck to be born with a certain no no
like I couldn't sing I couldn't sing for
[ __ ] now I can sing I'm not I don't
sound like [ __ ] Sam Smith but I can
sing right but I couldn't before I
couldn't play the piano okay what about
someone like Jimmy Lee EULA who's Jimmy
Lee okay
so Jimmy Lee is ways there another P
break because I have to pee so bad you
can you can run go to the back I'm sorry
guys I'm gonna I'm gonna go pee really
quick that's all good you guys talk
about Jimmy Lee yeah that's a great
thank you long to describe who J yeah so
what do you think about Jimmy Lee's case
cuz he works hard he is dedicated he
emails me every day his new videos
that's full dentist that's true you
don't get you don't get to be everything
you don't get everything okay you get
something ready that's a good point yeah
you worked hard and hard and hard and
you didn't make it show me so people we
don't know Jimmy Lee is like he's a
dentist and then he decided to try to
become a comedian when he it's not gonna
ball he yeah but he's a successful
dentist extremely stylist you wonderful
dentist a few offices and multiple
locations doing really what bubs yeah I
don't know that I consider luck to be
the things that are completely out of
your control everything else the work
the learning the dedication the
sacrifice that's not luck you know what
I'm saying you got to accept some credit
there's a certain level of humility
where you're like you want to be like oh
yeah no I was I was lucky you know you
you want to be humble but sometimes I've
always liked Jerry Seinfeld's take on it
and he doesn't like to think that
anything is lucky
well what's useful about that he's very
he's a super hard-working oh yeah
comedian and he's very meticulous and
tedious in his writing and like he's
every word has to be the exact right
word to be funny and he when you ask him
about that I've seen him talk about it
he's not really like accepting that
statement of oh I was lucky you're
telling me there's comedians out there
that were more dedicated than Jerry I
mean Jerry is like a max dedication
mm-hmm his life every breath he took
every moment every day is also a genius
yeah buddy
but yeah I don't know I I always had a
problem with this question cuz it's a it
is a question the problem is that it
doesn't do anything
did you pee that fast bro what never
[ __ ] you like teleported video a real
MIT dude that was a fast world record
holy [ __ ] I wanted to leave people
hanging I'm like legitimately out of
breath yeah I appreciate that I think in
short the answer is that question
doesn't help anyone it's like this
question do we have free well it's like
who cares it doesn't do anything you
just [ __ ] let me just [ __ ] on this
guy's question I love my problem for
example your answer said you said that
you're lucky to be born here well I
wasn't I was born in Israel right I'm
here now so I don't know it that was my
luck though hey can I ask you guys a
really quick question yeah yeah what is
your I'm just curious because I see some
people do and some people don't reason
you don't rare wear wedding bands oh I
just find it awful it's annoying it's
really I am OCD about it I don't I don't
care about the whole like
symbolic yeah I have my wedding ring
I'll wear it sometimes but I just I have
a different ring that I find more
comfortable is it just so you get hit on
when you go to the club I just gonna say
I don't even go to clubs he's in the
club he's like yeah mistake us first
thing Elkins we're always together and
we we don't go out really to clubs
I was another guy yeah I was really good
to wear my wedding band when we got
married and I worked for like three
months but I'm I'm really OCD yeah and I
was just fidgeting with it all the time
it was just driving me crazy
yeah okay yeah so comments mm-hmm
questions and yeah next one
thank you yourselves even though we
trashed you dougies asks hey Bobby long
time rat-pack member here what is your
favorite video game currently or which
one are you most hyped for in the future
oh man that's a good one
can't wait for the last of us to so
that's a big one for me and my favorite
video game currently the office season
he's in a revolt I don't know I got
really baked last night it was playing a
super meatboy I'm just so into there me
I just love it right it's so fun maybe I
should hit those devs and see if they'll
make my game that'd be sick right you
should hit those already have a title
and everything but I don't say is it
Bobby boy
[Laughter]
I've been playing Kingdom Hearts is it
good I never it's the worst [ __ ] game
but I still keep playing it so it
doesn't make any sense
the combat is insanely stupid you're
you're triggering the [ __ ] out of you
note here the dialogue is the dumbest
[ __ ] so what I do is I mute the game I
skip every cutscene I've been listening
to Howard Stern while I play and I mute
it I skip every cutscene and um it's
tolerable that way nice yeah oh I read I
read a 5 out of 5
ok ask em everybody in is like red in
the face right now
Ian it's you have to admit in even if
you love it and you cherish it and you
know it's part of your childhood and
sequels so exciting you have to admit on
some level that it's awful
I'm just gonna mute you like you mute
again you're being cheeky but I want to
be real I mean it like you think that
the voice acting and the dialogue is
good I don't want to get into it's to my
gun all right next question from Peter
Vanek
oh I'm skipping ahead oh Jesus Christ
listen let's take it back danger moves
one two five
Sinatra gained you get a lot of flack in
the industry from haters too even your
own fans trying to tell you what to do
how do you stay true to yourself despite
all the people actively trying to change
you that's a such a great question you
know that's so gnarly um man how do I
answer that I I am the same person in my
heart that I've always been I've changed
it matured and grown as just a human
being and as an artist and all that but
like the values and what I represent and
what I do are the same when I record a
turn up song I do that because there are
so many people who really enjoy
Bobby Tarantino you know that that like
that Lane of music when I make boom bap
hip hop I do that for those people you
know when I have this supermarket
soundtrack there's gonna be it is not a
hip-hop album period and a lot of people
could be like bah bah bah but then I
have another album you know it's there's
all these these things that people can
say and do say but a true fan of
somebody is gonna love and appreciate
them no matter what and they could sit
there and say to themselves like oh this
song like a real fan points out the
things they like about something before
they then go but you know I like the
beat better on this song or I like I
kind of like the the more turn up stuff
because it's fun with my friends when
we're just hanging out having a good
time you know or whatever so I just
don't really think about it whether it's
fans or haters or this or that because
like I always say I make the music for
the people who enjoy it not the ones who
don't it's just the it's kind of just
like the most honest thing ever the
gnarly [ __ ] is when you have people to
be like oh he's changed or he's only
doing this for this like like when 1/800
came out the song there was all these
people like oh he's making songs just
for the radio and it's like oh yeah yeah
I was in a studio like man when a song
about [ __ ]
often yourself be like the best
marketing ploy of all like no way dude
like I you know I'd traveled the world
and had people say that my music saved
their lives and I was like holy [ __ ] I
didn't even try so imagine if I actually
took the time to just write a song from
the perspective of somebody who's really
going through it you know to me because
I know what that's like and I just did
it and I did it from a place in my heart
of love and happiness and and hoping
that it would just be there for anybody
who might need it the gnarly part is and
this is like not this is just fact there
was a lot of celebrities unfortunately
who took their lives and a span of it
coming out there was the whole 13
reasons why thing that was like you know
pop in and it was just all these things
and like mental health like I used to
get made fun of for talking about mental
health like just even a few years ago I
was I was in a Pittsburgh and I was
crying onstage because I was throwing up
just before I hit the stage I was so
Slyke messed up and yet I'm being told
like you know it just felt trapped like
I had to do you know 50 shows in a row
and I had to do this in Xyz blah blah
blah and I was just honest with the
crowd and I broke down not because I was
all like [ __ ] up I broke down because
I loved them so much and I was like I
don't even want to be here right now but
you make me want to continue and I love
you guys shredder ready he's feeling me
and I love you guys and and and you're
why I do this but even more important
than you guys is me and my my mental and
physical health and being happy with
myself so you know I've been there and
it wasn't a cool thing to do a song
about so that's not why it's not why I
do anything that I do you know I mean I
don't do it just because it's cool like
even in my turn up songs like oh yeah
sure I'll be like yeah all these [ __ ]
while my deacon blah blah blah but I'll
be like but can't [ __ ] with no hos need
a good girl though like if that's still
who I am as it as a person so when
anybody ever tries to like tell me who I
am or this or that I just remember these
are people who've never met me
anybody who shakes my hand and I have a
conversation with they're like oh [ __ ]
like I don't watch how do I introduce
myself Bobby I'm Bobby hey I'm Bobby
like when we sit down we do [ __ ] like
this okay yeah sure I'm logic yeah but
when I introduce you know myself to your
buddies helping make this show
incredible it's like I'm not looking
[ __ ] lot like these people don't know
who the [ __ ] I am so I just remember
that and I remember like that's okay
even the most die-hard fan who like
supports every little thing shredder
does he get a peek even the most
die-hard fan who supports like every
little thing that I do they still don't
fully know me you know and and it sucks
on both ends because it's like I wish I
could know every single fan but long
story short I do not let it affect me it
used to when somebody would be like oh
why are you talking about fortnight in a
song like why the [ __ ] does it matter is
that really what we're talking about
here what about all these other lines or
all this this and I feel like it's the
maturing process of every artist
involves confronting that yeah that
challenge people challenging who you are
and it's like you think you know who you
are but all of a sudden all these people
that don't know you are challenging who
they think you are yeah and there's a
really there's a real crisis of identity
that I think is only inevitable for most
people to go through we really struggle
with the concept of yourself and other
people's concepts of yourself I know
that's what I've been dealing with but
the biggest thing I talked to Jay Cole
about that when I was in it this was
like a while ago this is when I decided
to give up social media for the most
part and and I was like talking to him
and all these people are saying all
these things about me you know whether
it's like personal things or things I've
gone through publicly with relationships
or XYZ and all these people think and
they know why X happened or this or why
you suck or whatever and he was like why
do you why does it matter to you and I
was like what do you mean and he gave me
this really sick tip and basically you
just kind of interview yourself it's
it's like you interview yourself so this
is what I did this is how he had me do
it and I still do it and you go okay I'm
really upset that people think X about
me whatever it whatever it is why well
because I'm a good guy
okay cool you're a good guy you tell
yourself you're a good guy so why does
it matter that they know you're a good
guy well because I want them to know I'm
a good guy I'm not this person that a
TMZ tabloid has made me be yeah but why
does it matter and I'm like because yeah
but why do you want them to like you
well I guess because I want to be
accepted well why do you want to be
accepted because
it's human to be accepted okay yeah no
for sure it's human you want to be
accepted by your friends and people who
love you and care about you but you want
to be accepted why do you want to be
accepted by the people who blatantly
don't like you mm-hmm
well I don't know well think about it
why I guess because if these people and
these tastemakers and these blogs and
these hip-hop you know whatever accept
me then it'll allow me to feel better
about accepting myself and then you just
ask yourself these questions and get all
the way down to it and that's like but I
already accept myself so [ __ ] you like
and then but it's easier said than done
dude it really is you know people hate
Jay Cole I see a lot of [ __ ] they hear
gets in a cyclist oh your bathroom key I
saw oh thank you yeah we lose those a
lot we go I don't get that people I saw
a tweet I thought it was so great he's
like people who hate Jay Cole are just
weirdos because there's like because
people are just contrary they'll hate
anyone and it's just one of those
situations where it's like why do the
[ __ ] like that's it comes back to where
we are right now like there's a
difference like I've seen you guys rip
people apart mm-hmm for entertainment as
it as a joke you know and I've also seen
you do some very serious things like as
far as just like where you may stand
politically or whatever I [ __ ] hate
that all that but you know what I mean
just like your take on like the world
and that's okay but there's a difference
between like that and being an
entertainer and being on camera and
knowing exactly what you're doing and
then just really trying to hurt someone
yeah tear them down tear them apart yeah
and that's the thing is everybody wants
to be famous that's a real thing I'm so
excited for you guys to hear this album
I'm working on it's so gnarly and it's
about that it's about Fame and social
media and where we are as in society and
cliques and likes and and not just from
like the perspective of someone who's in
the in the limelight but somebody you
know a 13 year old girl in eighth grade
who's like looking at these like
Instagram models and saying oh well this
has more likes than your you know Jane
next door so I got to look like this or
I have to alter my body it's another
thing like even with like plastic
surgery and [ __ ] right I'm like hey do
whatever you want to do you know like do
whatever whatever you want to do to be
happy that's fine you know if a chick
wants bigger boobs or I don't know for
you know ladies in her 60s and doesn't
like her neck flap like okay if
something that's really bothering you
for you personally cool but what's
really makes me sad is when both these
men and women completely reconstruct
their bodies not for them but for how
they are perceived by others and that's
sick man that just that's the [ __ ] that
makes me sad and so when people come to
me and they're like because they're like
oh you know they could say whatever to
this this girl like you know your face
is this or your ass is that or blah blah
blah people say that to me about my
music oh you rap like this here and you
don't do this here and you don't do that
and that can make you want to change
mm-hmm and I've had to realize like no
I'm not gonna change because if I do all
that if there's this people over here
that are like change all this about your
album and then you'll be good mm-hmm
and then I change all that about my
album and all those people go everyone's
mad yeah but then they'll be like you
know you might have these people that
that's pretty cool that's pretty cool
that's pretty cool but then you have
your entire fanbase that loves you that
goes why did you change those people
will never be happy either exactly but
you'll never be happy if you want
everyone it's just it's it no it's sick
I know exactly what you mean man yeah
man god damn anyway but I will say you
can do whatever you want with your body
I don't give a [ __ ] no but you're right
you got it it's hard to know the
difference between if you're doing it
for yourself or for other people but
yeah there's such a like I mean you have
you look at to someone like Kim
Kardashian who was kind of ideal beauty
these days or something but her her body
is not realistically obtainable without
plastic surgery she's got a huge ass she
got huge fake titties her she's got
plastered all over the place it's fine
for her she makes it work that's you
know she's got a thing but people look
at that and they don't know that that's
not natural and they compared to their
own body
yeah like [ __ ] like why don't I you know
it's like dude that's not possible
that's that's literally it's like when
girls used to look through magazines at
models and they would say oh that's not
realistic because it's Photoshop you got
that in real life now you've got real
life photoshopped bodies walking around
yeah now it's pretty it's pretty gnarly
this wasn't no this is a super EXTREME
what I'm about to say but you know you
have indigenous peoples all around the
world who could do things like elongate
their neck or you know cutting into
their body and it's these things that
seem
you know sexy you're attractive or
whatever so they are all turret cutting
their lips in their ears and oh like the
gnarly [ __ ] now you know Beverly Hills
90210 like doctor like there's a big
difference but it's funny how in a way
it's like that you know that's our
society's way of making ourselves more
sexy or appealing it's weird yeah it's
pretty gnarly it is straight but it's
also cultural like there's times period
like now we were very much about the ass
that's what it's all about 10 20 15
years ago the ass wasn't really it
wasn't like that
yeah and I feel like in ten years
different fashions yeah but it was weird
cause like in 90s movies like you ever
see white women be like it's my ass fat
like all the white dudes but the
brothers were like hey you know what
black culture is is influencing culture
again
indeed booty that's that ass influence
now make that ass shake that ass girl
you know that song yeah that was in
whatever soda Rican already oh yeah
funny where richest party let me see
what you got I always thought it was
strange how girls were worried about
their ass licking big though I mean a
man I think women are beautiful
seriously like all colors shapes and
sizes they're not a woman a woman a
woman a woman to me what's attractive is
a woman who takes care of herself that's
it
that's the big that is the biggest thing
it's like if if she just takes care it's
not like you have to be this like insane
athletic or XYZ it's just like you eat
moderately okay and just exercise right
caribou talking about that recently
that's so much about what being
attractive is yeah just taking care of
yourself yeah that's it that's you could
be the most beat-up-looking [ __ ] up
genetically but if you look at and take
care yourself somebody's gonna [ __ ] you
yeah you know at any rate from
so just read her get the [ __ ] see
what I know he doesn't see what I did
there he is he is always snubbed he
[ __ ] everything that moves but I think
the girl the girl dogs don't like the
little the little guy you just got to
bring him over to my crib so he can hang
out with Stoney yeah you know why my
dog's name is Toni because every time I
smoke weed I say I'm buddy to get Stoney
and this she always come running when
you call her name yeah stoner baloney
gang Stoney this question comes from
Peter
Vanek giant logic fan and when I was at
his show last year in CT there was a
fight in the crowd and he stopped the
entire show mid-song to make sure
everyone was safe and had the girl
getting attacked come backstage was just
wondering what's the craziest thing
that's ever happened to you at a show
there's a couple things that have
happened I mean one time this like
really burly [ __ ] jumped on
stage and well I can come in at me Wow
he was just really drunk and excited but
like he literally broke you don't
understand yeah so Jordan him pet my
security guards where I think it was in
Canada and like I wasn't looking and
that's another thing when I perform I'm
never immersed in the music and it's
kind of sad actually like I'm always
looking at people like if somebody looks
really suspicious I'll go and I'll tell
somebody like yo this guy with the
trench coat like what the [ __ ] like you
know like legit like it's so but that's
just my upbringing right like I could
never feel like I could just relax and I
understand that it's not only am i a
target but so are my fans and I want
everybody to feel comfortable we're in a
gnarly time I mean it's always been
crazy really but anyway so this dude
like totally comes at me and I think he
was just trying to give me like a bear
hug my but I didn't see him and I was
turned this way and I was just chilling
like doing my little wraps whatever and
I see pet and he comes and his eyes are
wide he's like move and I just like jump
up on this like contrat mint on stage
and the guy just misses me and they just
choke in the hallways and do that yeah
that was one one of the one of the big
ones that comes to mind as I was on
I was on tour like 2013 and this kid
jumped off the second balcony and landed
on stage what and I think he might have
broke his leg
holy [ __ ] and he just gets at it just
like Falls and into like a surfing the
crowd my never that was crazy
I've had people throw [ __ ] onstage but I
don't [ __ ] with that oh yeah you get
kicked out real quick I'll stop the
whole you see him is it easy to tell her
through it a lot of there a lot of the
times you can see the direction and
people are people like it was this guy
do they call me sometimes they don't cuz
they don't want to feel like a snitch
but I'm just like but it's like dude
yeah an idiot who's willing to throw
something on stage like nah that's not
is not it's not happening but then yeah
I've seen I've seen people get punched
yeah I've seen like I've seen really but
you know who those people are they
aren't really fans those are those are
like the plus one when the super logic
families like Dan yo do you when it
comes like she logic and they're like
hey I guess they get shit-faced and they
like group someone and yeah but I don't
play that oh one time I was in Canada
and this girl she was like half drunk
and she walks up and she just starts
flicking me off as she's walking to her
seat like why are you here I stopped the
whole I slept the whole show and I'm
like why are you flipping me off what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you and she's
like oh she and she like starts hiding
behind somebody I was like no you're
just go through you really just gonna
flip me off like that like a [ __ ]
serious and she's like yeah [ __ ] you
Baba and I just let her stay cuz she was
just funny like she's just like a no no
she like intently meant it she just
obviously wasn't a fan of mine but I was
like what was were you headlining was
that yeah it's like what what are you
doing here yeah it's pretty weird
another another time I think it was
actually at the same show this is what's
really gnarly when like acts of God
stopped you from doing something and
people get mad at you so like it was
raining in Toronto yeah like in st.
there's lightning and I'm like I'm ready
to go on and do the show but the cops
are like no you are legally not allowed
to do this and then I was on Twitter
like damn you know this sucks like and
I'm seeing comments and one of them
Oh shredder one of them's like logic
you're such a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
you're really gonna I've been waiting
out here for you blah blah blah [ __ ] you
like and they really meant it and then
like I went back and I've seen like
tweets where they're like I Love You Man
and you're great and they're just so
torn and I went out on stage and I was
like because I looked for him and I sent
people into the crowd to look for this
kid because I was gonna be like [ __ ] you
and kick him out like why would you say
that like straight up and and so I
started the show and I'm doing that and
I'm all like yeah peace love and
positivity except that one kid who was
like [ __ ] you and [ __ ] your mom and all
this other [ __ ] and I was like you're an
[ __ ]
yeah but if you love that yeah probably
that's the thing you give them attention
they love it I just I'm just not a big
fan of bullying man like it's like I
don't like people who are just mean and
nasty and negative towards one another I
don't think it's fair I think it's kind
and I won't take it for myself and I
won't take it for anybody else I see
being uh being taken advantage of or
treated harshly you know a lot of people
that do it just think they're being
unnoticed and can get away with it so
when you have the spotlight on me like
hey dude yeah Blaine what you're doing
what's really funny is like I can't
explain exactly I'm trying to think of a
time but [ __ ] like that is actually
happened to me before
where somebody's been like so vile
disgusting and nasty and I'll like
retweet them and like call them out and
be like like but I'm not even like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] like I'm not like saying
the gnarly [ __ ] I'm just like like I'll
just retweet them and then like
thousands of people just destroy them
mm-hmm and then I get called an [ __ ]
right because all these people and I'm
like you know I don't hear these are
things you learn then I just don't do
that yeah I want to end on this note
I've got a an email for my quote biggest
hater and it was titled your biggest
hater and I was like oh wow this sounds
phenomenal I'm gonna read this email so
here's the email let me put the guy's
got a My Little Pony icon - of all
things sick hi Ethan cut I'm a TV series
driver I've watched your video and
futures for PewDiePie do you have any
guess how much you made me angry I'll
make a missile and Senate your house and
blow it up may you and your wife die I'd
be better it'd be better if you give me
your address I will bring a gun with me
and shoot you and your wife I am your
biggest hater I'd be ready to go to jail
no to go jail I would be ready to go
jail yes thing
but I would really feel good that I
wiped out a racist from this planet may
your pregnant dog and the puppy inside
of it die regarde XX yeah love you kiss
love the kisses love that he's like um
you're a racist and I'm gonna kill you
there's no that's great yeah no I I was
first so I like to know wait ow okay cuz
I was like this is the best one of the
best yeah a lot of likes bro
Thank You Man yeah you know so I so he
he saw that I tweeted it and he was like
um he's like dude I can't why did you
tweet that you got to take it down he
said please don't report it to the
police I don't know why I didn't take
that part I just took this part here and
I was like hey I hope you've learned
your lesson that you should not send
emails like that that post will stay up
and hopefully the FBI does not send that
report to India because the police won't
investigate
he's like oh I'm just a kid in India I
didn't mean anything and then he
responds but why did you report it to
the police you made a video disgracing
Indians and Indian culture received so
much hate that's why I sent the email
but nobody actually talked about it it
was nothing more than a joke I don't
even have a passport and guns are banned
in India and also there's no chance I
can make a missile I haven't even seen a
gun in him
oh my god I'm showing his email address
oh yeah buddy everybody just be [ __ ]
nice and like don't say anything please
don't it was an accident
these things happen can you do anything
about it figure it out it's it's out
there okay everyone that was a weekly
show you can cut to it for a microsecond
well now they know and that's all I
really - it's all good just like people
just [ __ ] be nice anyway say he's a
sweet kid from India that I was just
messing with but he goes to continue now
he's not that [ __ ] sweet well he's a
little [ __ ] but you know he said right
no you know what you know what happened
is he got dogged publicly and was it
came back with his tail yo he threatened
to murder your own cousin posted it on
Instagram too and she was like what is
going on you see I was blown away by he
says he goes uh I don't know how to make
a missile there's no chance I could even
go to the United States even when I
travel alone in my own
even I never traveled on my own City
what will happen after the police
investigate will they come here please
tell me that nothing's gonna happen to
me yeah I don't know but I don't know
here's a crazy thing this is every day
for us yeah every day somebody's trying
to kill you or murder you or that you're
terrible that you're stuck and
[ __ ] wonder why we're humans
and our feelings get hurt they think
that because we are successful or famous
or that that [ __ ] shouldn't affect us
but again we are biologically human that
[ __ ] we are not immune it's not it's not
fun to know that someone out there
doesn't like you it's first of all bad
for you being yourself yeah it's like
you know why do you dislike me yeah no
there's a sign Phillips about that one
that one short when Jerry's girlfriend
dislikes George crazy and he falls in
love with her yeah like that I want to
[ __ ] this kid you know but you know you
know that Seinfeld would not hold up
today you're aware my dick my brothers
yeah well on that note oh let's put this
play off with that is that it yeah I
think we're good that's it I mean we've
been going for two hours
what's up two hours and are you serious
yes what's the longest podcast ever done
Wow not fair we did it our charity
stream okay I was but a normal one I
guess like three hours yeah we did like
three and a half those are too long
though to be honest with ya really those
are tools I'm having fun
yeah I guess now the music's already
playing all right I appreciate you guys
thank you so much
h3 h3 podcast okay I want to say guys
make sure to check yellow stuff
destroyed that's the theme song yeah
oh and I want to say story I want to say
to everybody check out super market
coming out in March they can be
pre-order now on Amazon it's there it's
available to be no I'll play for you
guys you just come to the crib I play
for you in my studio and do it again
okay you can if I can break your finger
off no no freaking engine master they
can punch the audio book which is not
available for purchase yet but it will
be is completely read by myself
that's amazing have you been have you
been working on that for a while yeah I
got to finish I got like another three
hours to go but it's really quite a lot
of reading I do voices and [ __ ] mm-hm
yes I'm gonna listen like you can see go
beyond inaudible yeah Shay's gonna be
everywhere I'm gonna have like [ __ ] I
have so many credits inaudible you do
their bite seven times really I have
seven credits I'll give it all of you
alright thank you
please I love the book cover oh yeah the
art I didn't have to fight for it but my
publisher it's great what do they want
my poster just was like they want it
they wanted Sam Spratt the guy who does
all my albums to do it let me open the
cover which I get but I don't really
give a [ __ ] that I'm saying this they
wanted to change it and I was like [ __ ]
now the fact that it is so simple and so
easy it's not a flashy thing I just want
you to enjoy it
that is perfect you really for it I mean
it doesn't really get better than this
there it is it's gonna be a different
size though I found out that it's just
gonna be a little bigger which isn't a
big deal I'm gonna do a later edition
that's exactly like this but I wouldn't
have been a I wouldn't have been
eligible for a New York Times bestseller
yeah and it's looking guys yeah it's
looking like I'm already gonna be from
that Olga's teller out the gate which
I'm really excited major time sales yeah
but they were like it has to be eight
inches by this because the literary
world and I'm saying this is so stupid I
almost didn't do it I like almost like
[ __ ] that it's like the people buy it do
people read it yeah they're like oh yeah
but I mean I get it I mean there is a
it's just a way that they've done thing
on a book unless it is 8 inches nice
well they got at least it wasn't too
late yeah yeah that's true and yeah so
it's cool
so I'm excited guys
Supermarket on Amazon go fricken listen
I'm excited for that I'm excited for the
new album everything you're working on
and I very much appreciate you can hit
it hit it
welcome to Papa's house goodbye I am so
excited that you came here
thanks sponsor the sponsors today were
Paul's new genius money and stitch fix
thank you for supporting us of course
and it'd be really cool if Nike could
give me my own shoe Nike please get a
hold of my own you know what I want to
call it
Nike let's what I want to call it the
actually I can't tell you ok
Nike the bobble push the Bobby swish the
Bobby swish you want to hear my yeah you
know I want to join you on a on a this
is a night honey what if you go in time
sounds are off way you're missing
something really important I just wanna
be able to hold on let's let's get out
of this fever I would love to do really
great but we gotta go we gotta like like
[ __ ] on some super pcs so what I'd love
to do is uh there's a format that I
absolutely love to do with you I'm gonna
find the perfect video I'm gonna be like
this is it can you do it in white vase
[Laughter]
I'm such a fan of you guys you guys are
great people thank my family because
you're sweetheart you were a try your
Europe I'm a sweetheart you're ruining
my day raining yeah dude HP called me
sweetheart I think being a sweetheart is
cool not me too I said somebody was
really sweet I said a rapper was really
sweet once and they were like what the
[ __ ] yo dude so it's always a sweet
[ __ ] [ __ ] I can sit here and talk
with you can say you're worried about
like the hardest dude though it doesn't
contradict this yeah it does it doesn't
contradict it I really want I really
want to do my own podcast I've thought
about for a long time should I think a
little nervous though I don't know why
what the [ __ ] am I gonna talk about it
does I wish I could be like you and say
all this [ __ ] I really want to say
trouble cost me a lot of anyway we
should end right yeah
guys thank you so much for watching next
week will be your first guest I mean you
probably have people more interesting to
us hila cares about next week show is
over forever no there's the pinnacle
this is Bobby but again just go back
it's a piece of art yeah you can cut us
off down thank you guys